first tonight the Democrats crazy train
as yet another passenger because there
is well crazy Uncle Joe Biden after
delaying his launch and then delaying it
again he has finally now jumped into the
2020 race he is now the 20th Democrat
running for president that's a record
now what's gonna happen next is gonna be
pretty remarkable as Joe Biden tries to
court the new ultra radical extreme
socialists left Democratic Party and
convinced them well he's their guy but
even the bigger story is overseas and
that's surrounding Joe Biden shady
involvement with Ukraine breaking
tonight also if you remember John
Solomon explained on this program while
Joe Biden was vice president his son
Hunter took a lucrative job at a major
Ukrainian energy company and by the way
there's also Peter Schweitzer on the
China deal but when the company became
the subject of a corruption probe in the
country
Oh Biden used his influence and your
money to literally get the lead
prosecutor fired bragged about it will
play the tape as solomon reported the
prosecutor was actually investigating
Biden son and Biden used the threat of
pulling US state aid dollars your tax
dollars if they didn't fire the
prosecutor this is a huge developing
story let's take a look and remind you
of what he had said we're not going to
give you the million dollars they said
you have no authority you're not the
president the president said I said call
him
I'm tell you're not getting a billion
dollars I said you're not getting a
billion I'm gonna be leaving here I
think it was watch six hours I looked I
said believe in six hours if the
prosecutors not fired you're not getting
the money well son of a oh six hours
American money same guy
really okay investigating your son now
we have been reporting on Ukraine
attempting and admitting they tried to
influence the 2016 election they are
offering this country the evidence on
behalf of Hillary question now is where
are all the people that are so worried
about collusion now tonight the story
surrounding Ukraine gets even murkier
because John Solomon breaking news right
now a new bombshell piece that details
how the Obama White House actually
worked with Ukraine to give the Russia
collusion narrative an early boost
joining us now to explain is the Hills
John Solomon John this is huge yeah it
is it's the first known instance where
we have the Obama White House very early
just as Donald Trump is rising in the
polls even before the first primary
election getting involved and what
happened was the Obama White House the
National Security Council invited all
the Ukraine authorities over the
prosecutors anti-corruption
investigators held a meeting in January
2016 just before the beginning of the
primaries and said listen we'd like to
find some new way to reinvigorate an old
case this was a case called the Party of
Regions case the case where there was
money being paid to lobbyists like Paul
Manafort and also the former Obama White
House Counsel Greg Craig they asked it
could you help us get that restarted it
set in motion this mad scramble in
Ukraine ultimately results in the
discovery of a ledger which gets leaked
with only Paul manna for its name they
left Craig Craig out and that starts the
whole Russian collusion case so what you
have is is is the beginning of a of the
Russian collusion narrative starting in
the Obama White House all right John I
thought we were going back to the tape
John thank you let me ask you this
because we showed the first tape of Joe
Biden but now how certain are we that
they have evidence the this prosecutor
that he was telling on tape bragging
about having gotten fired using America
money how certain are
we that that prosecutor was
investigating his son at the time
oh it's irrefutable I have in my
possession documents from the Ukraine
general prosecutor's office said state
that they were one of the questions and
one of the people they wanted to
interview was hunter Biden specifically
about three million dollars now that's
the figure the Ukrainians came up with
separately the FBI came up with your own
bank transactions in New York going into
a company controlled by hunter Biden
same amount of money three million
dollars out of Ukraine from that energy
company briefs m'x into the united
states so the FBI and ukraine have the
same evidence the question is what was
that money for and was it in any way
improper that's what needs to be
investigated in the ukrainian
authorities would like to provide that
evidence as joe biden now begins running
for the president we're pretty amazing
John Solomon thank you for that report
we're gonna ask the president for his
reaction in a few minutes now beyond
Biden's shady international dealings
well he faces an uphill climb and
already doing everything he can do to
try and cozy up to the far left of his
party look at his roll out video I
believe history look back on four years
of this President and all the embraces
as an aberrant moment in time
but if we give Donald Trump eight years
in the White House he will forever and
fundamentally alter the character this
nation who we are and I cannot stand by
and watch that happen who we are record
low unemployment for african-americans
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans women
in the workplace
oh and youth unemployment we have
literally wage growth stagnant for ten
years really now it's back better
stronger than ever that's hateful
that's bad for America I don't think the
American people think so despite Biden's
attempts to appease this far left
radical socialist base of the Democratic
Party oh they're already sounding the
alarm against him now in a new tweet
from the group Justice Democrats the
same group behind the rise of
congresswoman Alexandria Acacio Cortes
who I call Speaker Nancy Pelosi only a
name only
well the group wrote Biden his quote out
of touch with the center of energy in
the Democratic Party today and don't
forget congressman Acacio Cortes already
went firmly on the record she does not
want Biden to be the nominee and will
remind you this idea that we can go back
to the good old days with Obama with
Obama's vice president and I think you
know there's there's a there's an
emotional element to that but I I don't
want to go back I want to go forward and
look at this article from the liberal
website slate comparing Biden to Jeb
Bush calling him a weak establishment
candidate a headline in the AP reads
quote some women of color frustrated by
Biden's presidential bid raising even
raising even more questions about his
campaigns appeal based on past
statements on integration and busing and
get this it looks like Biden may not
even have the backing of his old boss
Barack Obama and the best part is is how
Uncle Joe's trying to spin this well
uncomfortable truth take a look
why didn't President Obama endorse
I asked President Obama I'm not to
endorse and he doesn't wanna listen we
should whoever wins this nomination
should win it on their own merits
great question Peters anyone actually
believe that anyone actually believed
that Barack Obama was all set to endorse
him benjoe stopped him well not your
heart be troubled Joe because the big
coveted endorsements already rolling in
like from conspiracy TV darling
disgraced indicted attorney Michael
avenatti tweeted this about Biden he
offers them as the very best chance in
2020 especially in key states he has the
fight intelligence fortitude to beat
Trump and begin to make America America
again he has my enthusiastic support and
Biden bragging saying all these foreign
leaders are begging me to save the
country in the world really getting a
little Messiah Complex anyway remember
Biden enters the race already trying to
fend off scandal after scandal multiple
women have accused him of inappropriate
touching kissing touching actual video
footage of Biden's disturbing touching
antics doesn't this alone immediately
disqualify in the eyes of the Democratic
Party it Biden was a Republican what
would they be saying the double standard
is on full display now our friends over
a campus reform decided to ask college
students what they think of his behavior
this is interesting let's take a look
what's your initial reaction when you
see these videos that's really creepy
I'd say it's a little on the strange
side and they've got a lot like they've
got a lot of different clips there which
is obviously doesn't look very good for
Joe Biden's definitely creepy that
various of Ages of women twos does not
just it was young women and
a little bit older women so it's just
very wrong and that should not be thing
yeah I think it's a classic example of
men not not responding to being around
women properly oh and there's a report
tonight New York Times that he called
the Neeta Hills she was not particularly
impressed that he understands his
position back during the Clarence Thomas
hearings that trouble there now despite
all these early troubles President Trump
did offer a warm warm welcome to former
Vice President Biden tweeting quote
welcome to the race sleepy Joe it will
be nasty you're gonna be dealing with
people truly have some very sick and
demented ideas but if you make it I'll
see you at the starting gate and by the
way I wonder if the media will ever ask
crazy Uncle Joe about some of these
finer moments that he's had over the
years let's take a look you cannot go to
a 7-eleven
unless you have a slight Indian accent
what kind of a chance with a
northeastern liberal like Joe Biden
stand in the South better than anybody
else you don't know my state my state
was a slave state my state is a border
state my state is the eighth largest
black population in the country we've
got the first sort of
who is articulate and bright
Romney wants elected he said in the
first hundred days he's gonna let the
big banks once again write their own
rules unchain Wall Street they're gonna
put y'all back in Chains of course now I
need a hill not a fan and it's touching
and his gaffes and his creepy behavior
may be in the spotlight but he has even
bigger scandals brewing remember Biden
has to run on Obama's economic failures
that was Biden Obama their foreign
policy blunders like the ridiculous
Iran deal and you could expect another
apology tour for America who would ever
drop a hundred and fifty billion dollars
in cash another currency on the tarmac
of radical Islamic mullahs who chant
death to America and threatened to
annihilate America and Israel why would
anybody ever do that you want to go back
to that and even bigger than that a
question surrounding Obama's White
House's role in the biggest abuse of
power corruption scandal in our nation's
history
remember the 2016 Russian meddling that
all happened on Biden and Obama's watch
that means yeah they're responsible the
dirty dossier the rigged investigation
into Hillary the FISA abused the use of
an informant to spy on the Trump
campaign yeah it's all creeping closer
and closer to the Obama White House how
high up did it go how did this all start
what did they know when did they know it
Hillary Clinton too continues to fuel
her collusion fantasies saying she was
the victim of quote a Russian plot Wow
like we've been telling you an avalanche
of truth is coming cascading down it
will expose the deep state those that
abuse power and this attempt to unseat a
duly elected president we'll have more
later in the program